jetzt ist wolfgang kubicki bei und
übergangen hat ja die runde gerade
unüblicherweise schon gesprochen während
er noch gar nicht da war habe ich ja
jetzt wolfgang loos namen der gerade ein
dickes lob bekommen hier er hat in der
100 wohl ihrer fdp heute so abgeschmiert
ist herr kubicki nämlich hansjörg es hat
gesagt das ist der letzte der das
fähnchen in der fdp davon freiheit noch
hochgehalten hat in den letzten monaten
ansonsten wurde hier in der runde
geäußert das geschieht der fdp heute
abend völlig recht die hat nämlich ja
teilweise ihre werte verraten in der
letzten zeit die hat die glaubwürdigkeit
verraten verloren
ja was soll ich dazu sagen kann es ist
ein brillanter analytiker aber ich würde
diese aussage nicht sein dass die fdp
die werte verraten hat möglicherweise
ist das im öffentlichen bewusstsein
nicht ganz so durchgedrungen aber noch
einmal das was in nordrhein westfalen
fast jedes energie in schleswig holstein
hat überwiegend landespolitisch
grundlagen meine partei muss sich die
frage stellen warum wir waren über 60
jährigen so massiv eingebrochen sind bei
den wahlen das ist ja ein
strukturproblem und da müssen wir dran
gehen ist uns nützen 15 oder 18 prozent
bei den jeweiligen jungen leuten nichts
wenn die älteren menschen uns nicht mehr
wählen das ist die größte wählergruppe
und wir müssen da an uns selbst noch
arbeiten aber dass so ein
landtagswahlergebnis immer nur gründe im
land hat das ist ja auch ein stück weit
eine floskel an so einem abend herr
kubicki jetzt ist das die zweite bittere
niederlage heute kratzen sie sich gerade
noch so rüber wahrscheinlich über die
fünf-prozent-hürde werden sie trotzdem
anspruch erheben dort zu regieren also
mit der spd und mit den grünen wollen
sie eine ampel in nrw
selbst wie das nicht denn es gilt der
grundsatz dass in staatlicher hand ist
werden in eigener hoheit ohne dass der
bund sich einmischt ich war selbst stets
deutschland war derjenige der sich
gewehrt hat dagegen dass wir aus berlin
und aus bonn damals entsprechende
informationen halten wir uns zu weiten
haben aber ich vermute dass zunächst
erstmal die wahlgewinner diejenigen die
also herausragen guter jedes jahr
zittern gespräche aufnehmen werden und
dann wird man weitersehen noch kein wäre
das endgültige das vorläufige amtliche
endergebnis nicht ich vermute mal wenn
es für rot-grün reichen wird wird
rot-grün in nordrhein-westfalen
installiert werden und ansonsten wird er
auch schwarz-grün hinauslaufen hier sind
momentan nicht gehen die sich gedanken
über machen müssen in welchen
konstellationen künftigen afghanistan
politik macht ja das sind relativ klare
worte auch ganz klar gesagt sie sind ein
wahlverlierer heute
ich habe diese frage hier ist ein
bisschen laut jetzt nicht verstanden
können sie freundlicherweise wiederholen
mache ich freundlicherweise sind sie
heute wahlverlierer ganz klar
[Musik]
also mein heutiger abend wird so
aussehen dass ich meine enttäuschung
versuche zu kompensieren und ich hoffe
dann auf bessere zeiten denn eins ist
klar politik ist wie ein paradoxon
rauchen wieder runter es gibt bessere
tag und schlechte tage nicht nur bei uns
sondern auch bei einen anderen
beteiligten an ich kann nur dringend
davor warnen zu glauben dass ein
niederschlag für die fdp unser aus
bedeuten würde wir kippen damit nicht
aus den puschen wie kompensiert wolfgang
kubicki
wie ich das kompensiere ich gehe jetzt
was essen und ich gehe dann
logischerweise dabei auch ein wasser
trieb
letzte frage herr kubicki weil eben ja
viele glauben dass das doch irgendwie
was mit dem bund zu tun hat die
befürchtung wurde ja auch in der runde
geäußert hansjörg es hat gesagt die
falschen ministerposten hat sich die fdp
gekrallt im moment warum sind sie
derjenige diejenige partei die die am
meisten unter dem regieren leiden ist
regieren doch schlechter als sie gedacht
haben
ich glaube noch einmal in new york ist
ein brillanter analytiker aber etwas
längeres nachlegen hilft auch weiter ich
glaube und ich weiß dass viele unserer
video und wähler nach wie vor mit der
fdp in eine ampel auf bundesebene etwas
fremdeln und es braucht eine gewisse
zeit um hier auch eine anpassung große
sehr bei zu führen und wir wissen ich
weiß es jedenfalls auch uli hoeneß weiß
es auch die bedingung für ein gutes
wahlergebnis wahrnehmbarkeit und gerade
in den ländern nordrhein westfalen und
auch schleswig holstein war die
wahrnehmung unserer dortigen
übungsbeteiligung zwar vorhanden aber
suboptimal es hätte man durchaus noch
steigern können dann hätten wir ein
anderes ergebnis und ich glaube schon
dass die frage wer für eine
landesregierung in schleswig holstein
wie auch noch auszahlen auch viele
wählerinnen und wähler von uns dazu
gebracht hat anders zu wählen als uns zu
wählen weil sie eine bestimmte richtung
wollten und nicht mehr im kopf hatten
dass sie damit auch gleichzeitig die fdp
sprechen fragen kann wolfgang kubicki
der jetzt in diesem moment anfängt das
wahlergebnis zu kompensieren für sich
diese wahlniederlage danke herzlich aber
das gespräch hierbei das glas wasser